Salut Romain, ça va ? -Bof.
-Qu'est ce qu'il t'arrive ?  -Accident de capote.
Aaah, bah pilule du lendemain non ?
- non c'était hier. Faudrait que je prenne la pilule du "hier" du coup et ça ça n'existe pas.
La pilule du "hier" ? T'es sérieux là ?
Déjà, t'es au courant que c'est pas toi qui doit prendre la pilule ?
Ben...oui, oui !
Ben oui !
-Non.
La contraception c'est un peu comme un parachute :
la plupart du temps ça marche sans problème, tout se passe bien et on peut profiter d'un moment plutôt sympa et riche en sensations fortes.
Mais pour pouvoir en profiter pleinement, c'est bien de savoir que si par hasard le parachute s'ouvre pas,
on en a un de secours. En l'occurrence le parachute de secours c'est ce qu'on appelle la contraception d'urgence..
Romain, ça ne t'intéresse pas ce que je raconte ?
- Bah c'est pour les filles non ?
Ah d'accord. Donc ça te concerne pas, les rapports sexuels non plus du coup ?
-Ah si, si, si! oui bien sûr !
Et oui, parce qu'en vrai ça concerne tout le monde donc :
écoutez bien.
Oui donc, la contraception d'urgence
c'est le parachute qu'on ouvre quand le premier parachute ne s'est pas ouvert. Pour être clair on y a recourt quand on a eu un rapport
sexuel à risque de grossesse. C'est-à-dire un rapport sexuel sans aucun moyen de contraception
ou avec un problème au niveau du moyen de contraception utilisé. Comme un préservatif qui craque,
un oubli de pilule ou un problème de timing quand on utilise la méthode du retrait.
"Sort, sort, sort sort"
Ah oui, au passage des spermatozoïdes y en a dans le liquide séminal.
Vous savez celui qui prévient pas trop quand il sort là. Donc la méthode du retrait...
En gros, il y a deux possibilités :
se faire poser un stérilet en cuivre, en urgence, ou prendre la pilule du lendemain. Alors bon qu'on possède ou pas un vagin et un utérus
j'imagine que tout le monde voit à peu près ce que ça donne la pose d'un stérilet en urgence.
Donc on comprend vite que la deuxième option, c'est moins compliqué. D'ailleurs de loin, c'est le moyen le plus utilisé.
Et pourtant dans ce domaine comme dans pas mal d'autres on entend dire tout et souvent n'importe quoi alors c'est parti pour un petit point
sur sept bullshits sur la pilule du lendemain.
Alors non! l'expression "pilule du lendemain" c'est un peu un double abus de langage.
D'abord parce que, non, il n'ya pas besoin d'attendre le lendemain
prenez-la dès que vous pouvez après un rapport sexuel à risque de grossesse
le plus tôt, c'est le mieux
Ensuite parce que ça marche encore le surlendemain.
En fait selon le modèle de pilule on peut la prendre jusqu'à trois voire cinq jours après
Dans le doute posez la question à un professionnel se serait quand même bête de passer à côté à cause d'un malentendu
En france les mineurs à peuvent l'obtenir anonymement gratuitement et sans ordonnance en pharmacie
On peut l'obtenir aussi dans les mêmes conditions auprès des infirmières scolaires dans les collèges et les lycées,
dans les centres de planification ou d'éducation familiale
et les services médicaux dans les universités si on est étudiante. Et qu'on soit bien d'accord
il n'y a aucune honte à la demander.
Mais ça on va en reparler. C'est la loi vous y avez droit.
Pour tous les autres cas de figure vous pouvez acheter la pilule du lendemain en pharmacie,  même sans ordonnance
Dans ce cas là le prix varie entre 3 et 20 euros.
Et  si vous avez quand même une ordonnance la sécu rembourse 65 %
Alors non, pas du tout! Parce que l'idée c'est d'agir avant la fécondation
c'est à dire d'empêcher la rencontre entre un spermatozoïde et un ovule.
Et éviter un truc qui a pas encore eu lieu même chez les plus
c'est pas un avortement
Jamais!
Non... non plus. En fait, voilà comment ça marche :
la pilule du lendemain, elle modifie l'action de l'hormone qui est responsable de l'ovulation
ce qui a pour conséquence de retarder l'ovulation le temps que les spermatozoïdes
soit plus assez en forme pour féconder l'ovule
C'est à dire pendant à peu près cinq jours..
Ouais ça se fatigue vite ces petites bêtes là!
Et c'est reparti mon kiki  - Je n'peut pas y aller... j'ai peur.. quand je vois ce trou noir j'ai le coeur qui lâche.
Mais ça agit que ponctuellement sur le cycle en cours
donc après tout rentre dans l'ordre pas de problème de stérilité
Ben non les effets secondaires qui sont le plus souvent observés
après la prise de la pilule du lendemain c'est les mêmes que ceux qui sont associés aux cycles menstruels
genre nausées, fatigue, tension dans les seins,
maux de ventre, mal de tête,  saignements dehors des règles...
mais c'est pas à tous les coups toute façon c'est temporaire.
D'ailleurs la pilule du lendemain elle est déconseillée ou contre-indiquée
uniquement en cas d'allergie à un des composants ou dans le cas de certaines maladies
Bah, c'est tout le contraire en fait.
Prendre la pilule du lendemain quand on a eu un problème de contraception... c'est super responsable!
Je vous rappelle que l'idée c'est juste d'éviter une grossesse non désirée donc ça revient à prendre la pilule mais le lendemain
Oui un peu avant un peu après on va pas revenir là dessus on en a déjà parlé.
Ce qui ne serait pas sérieux et encore on n'est pas là pour juger ce serait de dire :
Oui, bon, d'accord. Il y a un petit risque mais on verra bien.
Ah, et petite piqûre de rappel
pour avoir un rapport sexuel à risque de grossesse
il faut être 2
Enfin... minimum quoi donc pour gérer la suite c'est pareil
on s'impose pas mais on se propose au moins.
-Ben bien sûr
Voilà
...Alors non! Je rappelle que pilule du lendemain c'est l'expression populaire pour contraception d'urgence
alors dans contraception d'urgence c'est vrai il y a contraception mais il y a urgence aussi.
Donc non, c'est une méthode de rattrapage qui est pas efficace à 100% et qui ne remplace pas un moyen de contraception classique.
D'abord parce que c'est pas fait pour ça
ensuite parce que ça ne protège que pour le rapport sexuel qui a eu lieu avant la prise de la pilule...
et pas après
D'ailleurs les jours suivants il faut se protéger avec un préservatif jusqu'au retour des règles
Donc ça doit juste être utilisés pour rattraper un loupé. Voilà.
Allez, tant que je vous tiens enfin façon de parler
la pilule du lendemain c'est comme la pilule classique :
ça protège ni des maladies, ni des infections sexuellement transmissibles
donc à moins d'avoir assuré le coup dans les règles de l'art
La base c'est le préservatif!
Voilà dtc c'est fini pour aujourd'hui on se retrouve très vite pour une nouvelle vidéo d'ici là
protégez vous contre tout ce que vous n'avez pas envie qui nous arrive mettez vous bien et surtout
portez vous bien